welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's track on earth and human
management of our microbial wealth it's
my pleasure to introduce to you with dr.
Jonathan Shimon jonathan is a co-founder
and CEO of fit bionics a biotechnology
startup that is sequencing the
microbiome of elite athletes to identify
and isolate next generation probiotics
for applications and consumer health and
nutrition for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen dr.
Simon's keynote presentation is titled
mining athlete's microbiomes for next
generation probiotics my name is Hilary
Thompson and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roos is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credit
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Jonathan Shimon
I will now turn the presentation over to
him um this is Jonathan Shimon
co-founder and CEO of fit bio mix it's a
pleasure to be here on lab roots and
have an opportunity to talk about our
Reese
that's you know leading to sort of our
our company fit by omics
you know high-level we're a
biotechnology microbiome early-stage
startup we spun out the Harvard Medical
School a little over a year ago and
basically you know at a high level what
we do is we sort of look to sort of mine
the microbiome of elite athletes to sort
of identify next generation probiotics
that are either unique or enriched in
them and see how those probiotics could
potentially you know drive optimal
performance and recovery but then
ultimately sort of use this meta genomic
information and translate it into real
world consumer products to help promote
health to the masses so you know I'll
sort of go through today basically my
background story why I got excited in
sort of a microbiome research and why
athletics but also talk about some of
the science that was recently published
in Nature Medicine and then talk about
future applications and you know where
we could go from here
so I guess with that we could get
started I always you know kind of like
to start at the beginning I think every
story has a beginning I mean you know
I'm a scientist
you know I'm an entrepreneur but I
wasn't always that I actually was a
basketball player I always tell people
first and foremost I'm a New Yorker I
was born and raised in New York City and
actually I played basketball at st.
John's University so this is a Division
one sort of a basketball school well
it's a school that does a lot of things
but I think was also known for its
basketball program you know I was a
walk-on we we had pretty good teams I
was there from 99203 we want a Big East
championship we want an NIT championship
and for me personally I think growing up
in New York with hoop dreams in the city
I wanted to play in the NBA and be a
professional basketball player you know
there's some interesting statistics
associated with this and I think this
has been covered you know on the
internet and online when I tell my story
but you know
not a lot of people get a chance to play
in the NBA so I didn't make it but uh my
backup plan was getting a PhD in
molecular biology
so that's how I became a scientist sort
of as a you know because my primary
options didn't really become available
but um you know as a scientist and this
is kind of a bit of a joke you know I am
a big believer in you know natural
selection inform fix function and you
know I look at these statistics I think
it's easy to sort of laugh at these
things now but you know even from a
scientific perspective if you look at
sort of people that are able to overcome
these odds now a lot goes into this but
if you think about this from sort of a
physiological perspective you know these
are basically you know super athletes
are extremely beneficial phenotypes so
you know what if we were able to
understand what separates like you know
Stefan curry for myself other than you
know talents and training and greatness
but um maybe from a biological
perspective are there any differences
that could you know enable certain
athletes to sober overcome these odds
but then of course beyond just athletics
what implications does this information
app or maybe just you know overall human
health performance and recovery I think
society in general and I like to sort of
play around with this you know we're
heavily influenced by you know athletes
you know I think obviously this is a
play on certain commercial from the 80s
and 90s I think in general you know
athletes have a profound sort of impact
on our daily lives you know not just in
terms of sports or being fans or you
know watching TV but even in terms of
sort of emulating their performances how
active we are exercise certainly even in
terms of like economic decisions you
know things that we eat things that we
drink things that we buy to wear so you
know it is interesting the impact
athletes have on our daily lives and you
know the notion of how do we actually be
like these athletes how do we emulate
them I think right now the current
paradigm is you know we have to eat what
they eat we have to drink what they
drink we have to wear what they wear you
know I think one question
is does any of this really get us closer
to not only emulating them in terms of
their peak
you know performances really do these
things get any closer to optimize our
own personal sort of performances and
you know I think obviously coming out of
you know the Harvard Medical School and
the visa Institute for biologically
inspired engineering I think we take a
little bit of a different approach with
that by omics and the research we're
doing is you know what can we learn from
an elite athletes you know biology and
again how can we sort of use that
information to maybe drive you know
consumer health and nutrition you know I
think the old there was a joke I like to
tell like early on I think you know I
spoke with an NBA general manager and
when I was first telling him what we do
from a biotech and genomics perspective
I think the first question asked was you
know can we use genomics to predict the
next Michael Jordan and you know I think
mine is Roe and almost immediate
response was no but you know maybe to be
a little bit more provocative I think
the question I asked him was well you
know can we sort of understand Michael
Jordan's biology you know and maybe sort
of extract that and give it to other
people to help maybe develop the next
Michael Jordan or maybe even just
develop you know health you know
solutions or options for people even
outside of athletics so you know the
notion of like working with the most fit
and healthy people in the world
understanding them and then translating
that for everyone else you know I'll
take a little bit of a skipped ahead
I'll take a little bit of a detour here
you know talking about understanding
optimal physiology optimal phenotypes
optimal biology and decoding and
information I think for me personally
you know this is the real reason why I
became a scientist you know the notion
of genotypes of phenotype the notion of
form fits function I think for me I was
always excited about the diversity of
biology in terms of different organisms
different animals different species and
how each
has somewhat evolved to sort of have
unique you know physiology that may be
relevant for their environment that may
be relevant for survival
I think what really excited me early on
is sort of like understanding that from
a molecular basis you know and I think
you know when you get into sort of the
genomic era and I guess we're still you
know maybe I don't know fifteen years or
I don't know sixteen years since the
first human genome sequence was
published there's obviously still a lot
of information out there that we could
learn from but this is a concept that's
really I think influenced me as a
scientist and sort of something that
excites me a lot understanding the
blueprints from a genomic standpoint for
different you know life forms and you
know I will say this you know I was a
basketball player I'm a scientist I'm
very big into movies I'm very big into
pop culture and you know this is you
know something the notion of you know
everything around this life you know
could be architecture it could be sort
of government's various forms of society
but everything's sort of having a
structure everything have a good
blueprint everything I'm having sort of
a code and you know really what's
exciting is again what are the
implications and the potential
applications of understanding those
codes I mean imagine you know being able
to sort of see the underlying framework
from everything around you and then
being able to sort of interface with
that to optimize you know human health
or things of that nature and obviously
this is a scene from you know the matrix
which I love and I'm excited that they
just announced a matrix for that's
coming out fairly soon but um you know
just even from a health perspective and
understand genetic blueprints genetic
codes molecular foundations for human
health and disease you know imagine
understanding all that and then being
able to sort of engineer it or edit it
to sort of promote health and you know I
love this line you know what are the
applications of understanding the matrix
so you know I guess we'll use this from
you know molecular foundation for life
you know can we dodge bullets but know
if we can understand these things and
implications for health and disease
maybe we won't even have to dodge
bullets anymore we could sort of
engineer optimal how
and that could be through different
modalities and I think really that's it
what's the heart of biotechnology and
biomedicine right now again full
disclaimer and disclosure I am really
into pop culture here's a fun fact in
addition to sort of being a basketball
player and a scientist I grew up in
comic-con industry pretty much every
year of my life I've gone out to San
Diego comic-con and I've seen that
community develop you know from just
like a niche cult following that's
strictly sort of comic books to now what
it is today where it's all Hollywood and
all movies and you know billion-dollar
franchises and Disney owns everything
but um you know to kind of take this a
step further from blueprints for
encoding life I think a lot of times you
know certainly in the biomedical
community were very interested in
understanding disease you know my PhD
was in molecular oncology and you know
can we understand disease what doesn't
work and can we correct it to promote
health but what if we took an opposite
approach you know you know what if we
looked at for all intensive purposes
super beneficial phenotypes or
superheroes right and what makes these
you know superheroes unique and perform
novel tasks can we understand that from
a molecular basis from a genomic basis
and can we learn from that I'm you know
I'm huge fans I mean this was just in
the last year you know Black Panther
Captain Marvel spider-verse I'll just
admit I saw endgame in theaters probably
four times I've probably already seen it
around six times so heavily influenced
by the genre but I think that's also
exciting because you know I actually did
a postdoc because I was heavily
influenced by Iron Man and Tony Stark
and I saw the life style of him and
basically using technology as a
superpower I thought wow that would be a
pretty cool lifestyle so I do I'm a big
believer and you know this will tie back
into sports but just sort of popular
culture being infused into Science and
Technology and creating sort of new
functional categories that could be
relevant to the masses so you know
we like to think of these superheroes as
make-believe but we'll tie it back into
athletics right you know our superheroes
real and going back to the point zero
zero zero zero zero one percent of
people that claim the NBA and it's not
even just the NBA it could be other
sports but for all intensive purposes
these elite athletes are superheroes
right I mean they run faster than us
they jump higher they're stronger their
mental toughness is off the charts
so you know again the foundation for
understanding beneficial phenotypes and
physiology and optimal health I think
you know nature is already selected for
these phenotypes and now is there a way
to work with them sort of understand
from a biological perspective what
actually works and I think this is you
know the underlying foundation for fit
by omics and sort of the research that
we're doing you know can we you know
sort of work with the most fit and
healthy people in the world can we
understand what makes them unique and
perform in an optimal level can we then
sort of mind that biological information
to develop you know consumer products
that can promote health to the masses
and you know it's a fairly
straightforward concept right work with
athletes sort of use next-generation
sequencing to decode their biology and
then translate that you know I will
again a major theme in this and sort of
state this again I'm a former athlete so
there's a lot of meaning for me to work
with the athletic community I think
there's also a lot of you know cool
collaborations that can happen between
science and in pop culture and athletics
is a medium but just even from a
scientific perspective working with
elite athletes is a proxy for
understanding optimal health and I think
that's something that we're excited
about and also just say you know we're a
microbiome company so I'm a little
biased but I happen to believe that the
microbiome is one of the more
translatable areas of research right now
it's something that is dynamic it's
something we could change with diet it's
something that we could extract
something that we could transfer it's
something that we could purify and you
know if we're talking about sort of
beneficial bacteria that's just
basically another word for probiotics so
really for us we want
mine the microbiome of elite athletes to
look for next generation probiotics that
we could then purify functionally
validate and they look to turn into food
beverages and supplements that everyone
could sort of consume to help make them
more fit or active or just support their
their daily lifestyles
I think everyone sort of knows this by
now I don't know if I need to spend too
much time but it's kind of a provocative
notion that we're more bacteria than
human this number keeps changing I think
it used to be we were ten times more
bacteria we're two times more bacteria
now it may mean it may be we have as
much bacteria cells as human cells and
I'm not sure where that final number
stands but I do know that we have
trillions of bacteria in and on our body
and I do know that this ecosystem is
collectively known as our microbiome
what I'll say is that you know this is a
continuously growing field and you know
forfeit by omics were pretty much
focused on gut bacteria certainly there
are more microorganisms in the gut you
know fungi you know yeast you know
viruses and certainly if you look at a
microbiome what's also exciting is it
extends beyond you know sort of the gut
there's obviously oral microbiome skin
microbiome nasal microbiome hair
microbiome you know vaginal microbiome
so I think this whole community of
microorganisms you know it's just
continuously expanding in terms of you
know what we're discovering you know
again I think from fit by omics
perspective again coming out of
biomedicine in my background I think the
paradigm in biomedicine right now is
look at disease physiology what doesn't
work what's broken can we correct it
again I think our approach is almost the
exact opposite let's look at what does
work and extremely healthy and
beneficial phenotypes certainly from
their microbial community and and what
are the applications you know over the
past 10 years I think this has been
firmly established that our microbiome
greatly influences our health our
developments our functionality certainly
from an early age all the way up to you
know adulthood and beyond I think it's a
scientist we look at these from a
perspective of
energy metabolism protein metabolism
neurology immunology I think if you look
at from an athlete's perspective we're
talking about endurance strength mental
toughness and recovery so again really
what fit by omics is is sort of doing is
again what's work with sort of you know
phenotypes that nature is selected for
being optimal performers let's try to
look to identify beneficial bacteria
probiotics that could drive these
physiological processes can we see
what's unique or enriched in athletes
and then sort of again look to translate
those into real-world probiotics you
know I mentioned I spent I was really in
George's lab at the Harvard Medical
School for six years I initially did
some you know in situ sequencing and
CRISPR cast nine research but then I
decided to go back to my roots and
athletics and then pretty much for
around four years worked on sort of
athlete's microbiome technology and we
spent a lot of time recruiting you know
marathon runners ultra marathon runners
rowers trained for the Olympics
you know we sequenced their microbiomes
we see how they compared to non athletes
we see how they compared from you know
to athletes of different sports but
what's really exciting as this cartoon
depicts is we actually tracked these
athletes in a longitudinal manner to see
how their personal microbiome changes
between performance and recovery phases
and then ultimately we look to sort of
you know sort of mine all that meta
genomic information and then look for
again you know bacteria that either
they're unique or enriched or you know
change over time and you know sort of
look into this information to see okay
this is interesting this is exciting
why don't we see if we could purify
these bacteria and do some functional
testing what's really exciting is you
know this culminated in a nature
medicine paper that was recently
published I think around two months ago
where we discovered some you know and
this was done in George's lab it was at
the VESA Institute for biologically
inspired engineering it was also in
collaboration with Alex caustics lab at
the Jocelin Institute for diabetes you
know
this was really exciting and you know
I'm gonna now talk about this research
you know obviously starting with you
know lofty goals and you know talking
about athletics and comic books but you
know now getting to the science aspect
of it you know where we discovered
basically a bacteria whose natural
function is to eat and break down lactic
acid convert that into metabolites
that's beneficial for the host and then
can actually promote endurance and
recovery in preclinical settings so it's
kind of crazy it's kind of cool but I
think this is sort of the nature of
science you know like I said this all
started around four years ago in
George's lab at the beasts and you know
I just remember the initial
conversations how do we design a product
project around this how do we start it
this is actually called a sports
genomics project and rose IRB approved
and we spent time designing it
you know actually started back in 2015
when we recruited athletes from the
Boston Marathon and I should also just
say to you know what goes into sort of
designing this study you know obviously
there's sort of like selection criteria
inclusion exclusion criteria you know
what determines if someone you know is
an athlete how many times a week do they
work out also it involve recruiting
sedentary controls which you know
honestly we're mostly just you know
scientists around the community but you
know enrolling them into this IRB study
you know the other thing I should say
too is you know obviously if we're
looking at the microbiome the gut
microbiome or collecting samples that
passage through the GI tract so this is
just a fancy way of saying we collect
you know hundreds of fecal samples from
athletes I think a fun fact is a 60% of
fecal material is around bacteria so
literally in each sample you collect
there's millions of microorganisms in
there that provide a wealth of
information and we can sort of you know
decode that but we do more than just
collect fecal samples we collected a ton
of metadata we collected hundreds of
answers on a food frequency
questionnaire about you know their
dietary habits you know their health
back
their athletic background and then
everyday we collected a sample we had a
daily annotation sheet where it
participants you notice what they had
for breakfast lunch dinner and he snags
their exercise routines how many how
many hours of sleep they had at what
time they collected their samples so
there was a ton of information that we
collected for this study this is
somewhat convoluted but I'll just
high-level background for sort of
microbiome analysis and what we do as I
mentioned we collect stool samples you
know the great thing about biotechnology
right now is how sort of accessible a
lot and you know products are to
facilitate you know research especially
in this space so you could buy a
commercially available kit that its
function is to basically extract genetic
material from you know feces so we could
you know collect that genetic material
and this is predominantly from the
bacteria that's in stool once we have
that genetic information we can sort of
model modify it in a format where it's
suitable for next generation sequencing
you know basically it's sort of taking
raw material and then giving us sort of
genetic sequences you know a TCG and
once we have all that information then
we sort of go to you know use
bioinformatic techniques where we could
run it through sort of search engines
and reference databases almost like you
know we're running sort of genetic
sequences through like a Google if you
will and then what that does is then it
sort of spits back out all the organisms
that these genetic sequences are derived
from so you can imagine you collect one
stool sample from an athlete and now you
have a list of all the microorganisms
that are in their gut now you can see
how that changes over time and now you
can compare that to other athletes you
compare that to non athletes and again
you have all this sort of information
and at a very high level this is kind of
you know what it looks like I remember
again this graph is maybe from four
years ago and this is from the marathon
study you know we had several hundred
fecal samples that we had a process you
know and sort of get back genetic
information
I think this initial
dataset was using a publicly available
software called chyme readily used by
the american gut and you know Rob
Knights lab that they developed the
software and basically each color here
well first of all each column represents
a different fecal sample that was
collected you know from an athlete and
then basically you know each color
represents a different type of bacteria
and I think when you first look at this
information it's very messy and it's
hard to know basically what's the make
of this but you know this is why you
need to work with talented sort of
bioinformaticians and statisticians
because they could sort of look for
signal and all of this noise and as I
mentioned this was a project that I
collaborated with Alex kostik with I
actually met him when he was a postdoc
at the Broad Institute and then sort of
how he transitioned into being a
professor and again I remember I sort of
provided them the raw data I think
around summer of 2015 and then shortly
thereafter he came back to me with some
initial slides to show what he found
from all this data and this was actually
one of the first graphs that he showed
me and basically you know what we did
was we kruta de round twenty marathon
runners we recruited around 20 sedentary
controls we collected fecal samples on a
daily basis for two weeks you know
before the marathon after the marathon I
should also just say something about
Boston you know for whatever reason it's
enriched and endurance athletes whether
that's running or rowing and I think
people in the Boston area know that the
Boston Marathon is a huge huge deal it's
a holiday it's on Patriots Day my first
day working in George church's lab
happened to be on you know the marathon
Patriots Day actually I think my last
day in his lap was around that time and
it's only you know fitting that I think
halfway in between that was the
foundation for this paper but anyhow you
know we collected these samples here's
another fun story just just as on
tangent while we're talking and while
we're being honest and open and having
fun here there's a lot of practicalities
to consider when running these studies
and there's a lot of logistical
sort of situations that you don't
necessarily think of when you're sitting
in the lab so you know we collected
fecal samples on a daily basis you know
I don't know 20 to 40 participants what
does that mean that basically means for
two weeks I was driving around Boston in
a Zipcar five to seven hours a day
collecting fecal samples so you know
there's I'd like to say I got my hands
dirty for this project but you gotta
sort of be willing to sacrifice some
things for the sake of science but
anyhow I'm sure you've already read this
and you've seen this slide but one of
the interesting things that popped up
with this is when we looked at sort of
these runners you can see here the blue
line or our runners right in the middle
is the day of the marathon one thing
that sort of you know popped out was we
found right after the marathon there was
a spike of this bacteria but the
interesting thing was its natural
function was to eat and break down
lactic acid I think this was a really
big light bulb moment for us because
lactic acid although the literature I
think you know a lot of people I think
lactic acid people still aren't sure
what it does or at least there's some
misconception about what it does in
terms of causing fatigue or burning
sensation I mean actually it turns out
it's an energy source and is mostly a
byproduct of exercise but in general
lactic acid is metabolites that
accumulates in the blood after intense
exercise and is associated with fatigue
not necessarily something that causes it
but basically here we found almost a
biological response in the microbiome
tap to exercise whereby you know right
after an intense workout or the marathon
there was an increase in a bacteria that
sort of eats a byproduct of exercise
that accumulates in the blood so this
was kind of exciting but you know it
kind of had our heads thinking for a
little bit well what are the temperature
applications for this what if we had a
bacteria that we could purify as a
probiotic and what if we could give it
to athletes before they ran a race and
could potentially you know prevent
fatigue you know promoting
or promoting recovery so again you know
I could just say after spending hours
upon hours upon hours upon hours of
collecting fecal samples getting this
sort of result was somewhat rewarding
and validated and made the whole thing
worthwhile but um it kind of gets better
from there you know that sort of
analysis was done with 16s you know
ribosomal DNA very high level looks at a
genus we then took it level further we
did comprehensive metagenomic sort of
shotgun analysis of these fecal samples
and we also expanded to ultra marathon
runners people have run a hundred miles
at a time as well as rowers training for
the Olympics and this was really to get
an assessment of the functional pathways
in these bugs and it turns out this
lactic acid eating bacteria is fairly
unique you know in its functional
capacity not only does it actually eat
you know lactic acid but actually
converts it into short chain fatty acids
you know as two tape primate and
butyrate what's what's kind of exciting
about that is these short chain fatty
acids are actually beneficial to the
host are associated with health I think
their production is indicative many
times of healthy you know guts and
microbiomes and phenotypes and
physiology lactic acid typically them
attack the metabolic pathway is you know
it's produced in the muscles you know
during anaerobic exercise excuses of
energy source when sort of your exercise
capacity outpaces your ability to use
lactic acid as energy source then
accumulates in the blood I think around
90% of it is filtered through the liver
in the kidney where it's converted into
glucose but here we have a bacteria
that's actually promoting alternative
metabolic pathway and converting a
byproduct of exercise which I guess is
you know by the time it gets to the
blood mostly wastes converting into
something that's you know could be an
energy source but also anti-inflammatory
and essentially beneficial to the host
so this sort of intrigued this even more
and made the story even more compelling
you kind of have a bug that might be
able to be used as a probiotic to
convert you know something that's waste
from exercise into something beneficial
for the host
you know we took them two step further
obviously I think there's a lot of
microbiome studies that are looking at
correlations right now different
communities different phenotypes what's
enriched what's depleted you know that's
all cool but I think really where the
field wants to go and where it's going
now is what does that mean
can you show mechanism of action can you
saw a causality so for us we're
obviously interested in not only just
you know observing this and athletes in
a longitudinal manner but can we
actually now purify this bacteria do
functional testing so this is just
showing you know after sequencing all
these fecal samples we could go back to
them we actually can culture them in
Petri dishes under anaerobic conditions
in the lab we were able to enrich for
these bacteria they're typically of low
abundance less than 1% in the gut
although they could still be beneficial
in such a low abundance level but we're
actually able to find conditions that we
could then purify them and isolate them
and we isolate several species of this
particular genus and then enable us to
do more sort of like functional
validation studies by the way you know
I'm almost tempted to stop at some point
and ask if there any questions in the
audience but I realize that this is all
being done own or you know video
conference and stuff like that so I
guess you know that's not an option
hopefully you know be able to address
any questions and a follow-up but um you
know as I mentioned we purified numerous
strains of this genus that we discovered
and you know marathon runners ultra
marathon runners and then we culture
them in vitro and you know for us the
first thing we wanted to do was confirm
that this bacteria could actually eat
lactic acid and actually convert it into
short chain fatty acids so we drew these
in sort of 96-well deep well plates you
know we grew them in media that was
enriched in sort of a you know lactic
acid and then we grew them for around 48
hours and then we actually took sort of
the cultured supernatants of these
bacteria and then we could measure sort
of the the molarity or the concentration
of lactate present in these cultured
supernatant the other thing that's cool
to mention about this is you know
lactate threshold is actually something
that's used by a lot of elite endurance
athletes a lot of times you
they'll use it to sort of fine-tune
their training and their performance and
actually they'll pick prick their finger
though they'll prick their ear and
they'll use sort of a monitor that could
rapidly detect you know how much lactate
is in their blood so if you see on the
right where I have the gloves we're
actually literally using the same you
know monitor that athletes use in their
blood we were just using it to detect
lactate concentrations in cultured media
and you know the cool thing is I think
physiologically the the molarity the
millimolar concentration of lactate in
the blood at resting levels is around
two millimoles per liter I think when
you reach sort of fatigue states it
could go up to anywhere from four to six
to eight million moles per liter I
should say this media had 22 millimoles
per liter so it was way above
physiologically relevant levels but what
you can see here is that basically in
culturing our bacteria that we isolated
from these ultra marathon runners you
know within 48 hours
it pretty much wipes out all of the
lactate from the system or the lactic
acid I think I'm using lactate and
lactic acid interchangeably I don't
actually think they're the same thing
but I guess maybe for purposes of this
discussion I'll sort of interchange them
more than that and we then took sort of
our cultured supernatants and we ran
them through mass spectrometry to look
at sort of short chain fatty acid
production and what we found is that
actually 40 hours after culturing these
bacteria and the cultured media not only
does it deplete lactate but it then sort
of actually converts it into per primate
or short chain fatty acids so this was
really cool we basically observed this
correlation you know in athletes an
increase of this bacteria we purified it
we then grew it in the lab and we found
that it's April - you know convert
lactate into short chain fatty acids we
then took it a step further right so
this was kind of exciting we then want
to say okay great
we know this bacteria could do these
cool things but what does that mean from
a physiological perspective you know
what if we actually did preclinical
testing and we sort of gave this
bacteria to mice and see if it improved
their performance and recovery so this
is actually
figure from the paper whereby we
basically did a crossover study where we
fed mice our lactic acid eating bacteria
we compared it to a control bacteria and
then basically we ran them on a
treadmill till exhaustion to see if
there was a difference in endurance we
did this sort of enduring Tet endurance
testing three days in a row and then we
switched the groups in terms of what
they were fed and what you could
basically see on the left and then you
know on the right is that basically at
every time point in which mice were fed
this lactic acid eating bacteria they
showed around a thirteen percent
improvement in run till exhaustion which
was very exciting you know and is also
pretty huge I mean I think if you talk
to an athlete out there and you say hey
we're gonna improve your run time by 13%
they'd say where do I sign up another
thing that I want to point out from a
scientific perspective is these were
quote-unquote normal mice you know I
think a lot of times in the microbiome
space or area or field of research you
see people doing Studies on germ-free
mice these are mice devoid of native
bacterial communities or you see them do
Studies on you know gene knockout mice
to sort of induce a certain disease
state or phenotype these were mice with
their own native microbial communities
that were basically fed this bacteria so
you know I guess as close at least in
mice as you could get to a real
physiological setting so I think the
fact that we're able to observe this
functional effects was barely was pretty
exciting to us so this was you know
obviously great for us the other thing
to point out too is you know we
collected blood from these mice 24 hours
after exercise and then we looked for
inflammatory cytokines and basically
what we observed is almost across the
board there was a significant reduction
in these cytokines that are associated
you know with inflammation
you know TNF alpha interfering gamma
interleukin 6 so again this was exciting
for us because we basically started off
by working with athletes sequencing
their mic
before and after the marathon observing
an increase in a bacteria that eats
lactic acid we then purified this
bacteria we confirmed in vitro and eats
lactate and then converts it to short
chain fatty acids we then fed this
bacteria to mice and observed a thirteen
percent improvement in endurance and
then a reduction in inflammation after
exercise so this was pretty much pulling
to us and it was very excited exciting
and I think you know if you look at fit
by omics and what we're trying to do now
is we've made these cool scientific
discoveries our goal is to try and
translate this now into real-world
applications imagine having sort of a
consumer facing probiotic that could be
used not just by elite athletes but
everyone that maybe wants to be more
active or increased exercise capacity or
even applications beyond athletics so I
think you know this was really cool and
validated the notion of you know mining
elite physiology to look for next
generation probiotics you know I kind of
mentioned earlier I grew up in the comic
book industry I'm sort of a geek and I'm
a huge fan of Marvel but uh so you know
school have a little bit of fun with
this I think you know most people now
know Captain America you know and the
notion of sort of having these cool
superpowers and a lot of that was you
know developed because of taking a Super
Soldier Serum that basically gave
Captain America all these crazy powers
as our strength endurance and recovery
and what's kind of cool is you know
we're working with elite athletes and if
you just look at like Wikipedia or
googling Captain America and their
background and just says here you know
he has the strength the speed the
endurance and reaction times superior to
any Olympic athletes and if you actually
go step further most notably his body
eliminates the excessive buildup of
fatigue producing poisons and his
muscles granting him phenomenal
endurance and then it goes a little bit
into the super serum sodium if you
actually click on fatigue producing
poisons what comes out lactic acid
I like to joke with people this is
mostly because of my background in pop
culture and you know comics and stuff
like that you know maybe what we've done
and what physics is then is we might
have actually discovered perhaps one of
the ingredients for a Super Soldier
Serum so you know maybe we can help make
you know the next Captain America or at
least just make super fit individuals so
you know for me personally I think that
was an exciting accomplishment if
nothing else speaking of pop culture and
you know community and people being
excited about what we're doing I think
the excitement that this paper is
generated sort of been even beyond our
you know I don't know if I want to say
wildest expectations
but beyond our expectations I think this
you know might have been the highest
covered you know publication coming out
of George's lab and the beast' Institute
which is kind of saying something
because George church gets a lot of
attention but this was covered by over a
hundred and thirty media outlets across
this world you know New York Times LA
Times discover CNN NBC you know I think
it speaks to again this notion of yes
we're doing really cool cutting-edge
technology but you know sort of using
athletics as a medium to make it more
relatable to the general population and
I think again you know what are the
applications
you know extends beyond therapeutics or
disease but for just general health
wellness and fitness so I think what's
really exciting for us and again coming
from my background in athletics and sort
of pop culture it's again translating
the science into real-world applications
that everyone can sort of understand be
inspired by but also have access to you
know also just say you know a few more
things this is sort of extending beyond
I guess the publication now you know
obviously fit by omics is you know a
start-up and we're looking to sort of
develop consumer facing products I think
there's a huge opportunity and this is
really sort of the transition going from
academic research to now sort of startup
phase and Industry you know developing
technology not just for the sake of it
but developing technology that has
real-world applications and that could
be useful to people like we talked about
microbiome we talked about beneficial
bacteria but probiotics you know it's a
huge market a huge industry you know
it's a 60 billion dollar industry which
is kind of amazing and you think about
sort of you know how this could be
disrupted with new innovations and new
technologies also what's kind of cool
here is you know 90% of this industry
consists of two types of bacteria
lactobacillus and Bifidobacterium I
think if you contrast that with the
trillions of bacteria in and on our body
that help promote our health and
development there's a huge opportunity
to use technology to discover next
generation probiotics I can sort of
improve and disrupt this industry you
know certainly the lactic acid eating
bacteria is one of them but you know
maybe even within these sort of
bacterial groups there ways for
improvement and you know just transition
sort of briefly some of the other things
we're doing
I mentioned lactobacillus and
Bifidobacterium you know these are some
of the common species and strains that
are in the market it's kind of something
that's interesting and cool we're
actually really good also at isolating
these sorts of probiotic species from
athletes right so again we could
sequence their biomes we could look for
lactic acid in bacteria we could look
for other things that are unique
enriched but also this might be a good
place to start with these bacteria
because they're widely used in the
industry in the market they have a lot
of sort of you know value from a
commercial as well as even a health you
know digestion and immunological
perspective so you know we can isolate
these bacteria and you know some of the
things that were discovering is that
athletes have their own unique genetic
variations of these common existing
probiotic strains and species you know
the way I like to say this is you know
if you isolate a likely lactobacillus
from a Chobani and compared to one
that's isolated from like a Serena
Williams they're gonna be vastly
different probiotics and microorganisms
and I think this makes sense because
these bacteria naturally evolve and
cater to the physiological
of their host I think one thing that
we're excited about is again everything
we're doing is understanding optimal
health optimal physiology optimal
performance you know and then sort of
isolating next generation probiotics
that are sort of associated with that
help drive that help support that so you
know even from this very basic level
right if it's a sixty billion dollar
probiotic market that consists of mainly
lactobacillus and Bifidobacterium okay
great how can we look how can we mind
the diversity of nature and biology to
look for you know improvements over the
status quo so I think there's a lot of
cool things that fit biomes are doing
from just you know probiotics for
general gut health provides for
endurance and recovery and then
continuing to expand our platform to
even look for you know what's next out
there because I think we're just
scratching the surface and you know this
is kind of a joke but you know
ultimately for us the goal is it's great
we could discover these bugs we could
purify these bugs we could functionally
test them but ultimately we want to turn
them into food beverages and supplements
you know think of a kombucha you know
think of a yogurt you know think of a
pill or a supplement and basically can
we sort of use a diversity of these
delivery modalities to turn these
next-generation probiotics derived from
the most fitted healthy people into
world into consumer products for the
masses to sort of have access to you
know there's a lot of you know I skipped
something I think there's a lot of
applications with what we're doing I
mean even you think about from an
athletics perspective just having access
to this data right I think when we work
with athletes they're excited you know
about the technology they're excited
about learning more about their biology
they're excited about seeing how it
changes over time they're excited about
how this might be used to optimize their
training the recovery their performance
um how it can extend their careers and
what applications it has from a
personalized nutrition now you know one
thing I do caution say is that you know
we're at the very beginning you know of
this field and you know this this new
frontier so I think there's a lot that
we still have to learn and I think for
us it's important not to over promise I
think it's important to engage athletes
and engage the
and you know be candid and honest about
the technology where it is but we also
have to start somewhere I think the more
data we have the more samples we have
more athletes we work with the more
we're gonna learn so I think this nature
medicine paper is a first example of all
the cool and exciting things that you
know we could discover and then
obviously from a commercial perspective
turning those into probiotics turning
those into like ingredients for food and
beverage modalities so that's exciting
you know we're in the real world now and
I think we're trying to translate
discoveries that we made at Harvard but
also really excited about and being a
former athlete myself is continuing to
engage you know in the athletic
community that's working with no Olympic
champions national level champions
professional athletes and really
building this community people that are
excited about the science people that
are excited about sort of translating
this into you know products that could
promote health and fitness to the masses
and this is you know again these are
collaborations between the athletics and
science community is that we're looking
to foster and grow and develop so I'm
sort of like you know transition from
there obviously you know you need a
teams who achieve the dream and I think
for fit biomes perspective what we're
excited about is the diversity of our
team and its eclectic group of you know
scientists people and athletics people
in business people in marketing people
that could help us tell our story
because I think as we spoke about
earlier you know science is great but
you need to find a way to communicate
them convey that to general audience as
a UC George church here who was my
mentor at Harvard you see Alex kostik
here who was my collaborator when you
know he's a professor at the jostle
Institute but um you know we're really
excited about what we're doing and you
know I'd like to show this so it was
George you know this was one of my last
days at Harvard when we were getting
ready to leave even spend an outfit bio
mix you know I brought a basketball in
and I think George was exciting it was
actually raining that day and George
wanted to go out and play basketball and
I was like I think we'll pass on that
but uh you know I think we're excited
because again I think we're used to
doing a lot of it well George especially
developing cutting-edge technology that
could be helpful to people but I think
you know what we really
to find a medium to actually translate
that to the masses to make it popular to
educate people to help people and it
doesn't always have to be therapeutic or
disease based it could be general health
it could be wellness it could be Fitness
you know I always say George church you
know is one of the founders of modern
day genomics and he has around 20,000
followers on Twitter you know someone
like LeBron James has 40 million
followers on Twitter so I think there's
definitely mutually beneficial
collaborations that could be developed
between the athletics and science
communities and I'll just kind of finish
there as mentioned were you know an
early-stage startup company we're based
in New York and we're excited you know
right now with the technology that we're
developing translating discoveries that
we just went through into world
applications continuing to build our
community continue to work with athletes
and all sorts of folks so I think for
anyone out there that's interested in
learning more please get in touch with
us you could sort of scan this code
while it's up on your screen it'll
direct you to our website there's a lot
more information there you could reach
out to us via email you know you can
also follow us on social social media
and I think you know we're really
excited about you know building the
community the athletic community people
that are interested in the products or
the probiotics people participating in
the science so um you know we're excited
you know we appreciate the opportunity
to present this research to you and we
definitely look forward to you know
talking with many you and engaging and
continuing discussion in the future
so I'll kind of stop there I spoke a lot
but uh you know thank you for listening
for those of you that made it to the end
and thank you for the opportunity and
looking forward to having a chance to
speak with many of you down the road
thank you thank you dr. Simon for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible as
a final reminder dr. Shimon will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we'll see you next
time goodbye